the United States says the mission only
lasted a few hours but added it's just
the first in a series designed to test
China's territorial claims China is
building on coral reefs in the South
China Sea turning them into islands and
raising concerns they could be used as
military bases the structures are
located in the Spratly archipelago and
China asserts a 12-mile nautical
exclusion zone around them the United
States has now breached that zone
deliberately probing how far China will
go to defend its disputed claims Beijing
has reacted angrily a statement on
Chinese state television said the US was
picking a fight Beijing now says it will
start Li defend its interest in the face
of the provocation it says warn the USS
lawson when it passed close to an island
without permission philippine President
Benigno Aquino said he welcomed the u.s.
presence in the waters freedom of
navigation has been expanded and
propounded by all parties to the issues
of the South China Sea West Philippine
Sea and everybody seems to be
guaranteeing freedom of navigation so I
see no issue so this u.s. naval ship
traversing under international law in
waters that should be free free to be
traveled upon by any not belligerent
country the Philippines and many other
nations have claims to parts of the
South China Sea the waters include
corridors crucial for global trade and
the United States sees China's ambition
there as a threat